it's hard to believe but Thursday marks
three years since the final episode of
Breaking Bad aired on TV while it was on
Breaking Bad gripped the culture of more
tightly than almost any other show and
it's legacy is still intact today I
think because the arc of episodes that
concluded the story brought a satisfying
and brutal reckoning on what came before
I think the best episode of the series
can be found in that arc and today I
want to talk about that episode
Ozymandias the poem it references and
how the ideas in both help us understand
the show as a whole in a lot of ways
this episode though third from the last
book ends the entire series writer mora
wally beckett makes this explicit by
staging the pre opening credits scene as
a flashback to the first episode when
Walter White and Jesse Pinkman are
making their very first batch of crystal
meth the reaction has begun the
narrative of the show is its own kind of
chemical reaction brought about by
choices like Walters choice to make
crystal meth to raise money for his
cancer treatment like the first lie he's
rehearsing to tell his wife about this
that lead to the horrifying consequences
we're about to witness director Rian
Johnson makes these things explicit in
another way we're more Wally Beckett has
plot and dialogue Johnson has visuals
visuals like the slow fading of past
elements that show the passage of time
and the disappearance of the people and
the things that once were what we see in
this episode is effectively the bloody
end of Heisenberg's reign but what's
interesting is how not bloody it is
Wally Beckett and Johnson placed the
focus instead on reactions reaction
shots and so we get an episode of gazes
quizzical gazes angry gazes blankets as
penetrating gazes what's important isn't
that Walt gets away with Holly for
example but that Skyler sees it the
death of Hank has showed for all of two
seconds before ryan johnson quickly cuts
away compare this to the 44 seconds he
lingers on Walt's Skyler's flynn's and
Marie's reaction to that news so in this
episode we see Walter White
through the eyes of everyone else
including virtually all of the key
players in the show and as is often the
case these people see more about Walt
than he can about himself and the
smartest guy I ever met was my attendant
all these reactions these gazes makes
Walt's own tragedy even more stark it's
his inability to see himself through the
eyes of those around him other people's
gazes are like a mirror that we use to
see ourselves as Johnson highlights
twice in this episode Walt's not ready
to look into mirrors yet when he arrives
home later in the episode he uses all
his regular lines just listen to me
negotiate and everything is gonna be
fine both of you - trust me you have to
go right now but his words fall flat on
Skylar and they sound absurd to us Wally
Beckett uses these words brilliantly I
think as an extension of Walt's
blindness and this is the climactic
scene of the episode and the climactic
moment in the scene is not the fight
between Walt and Skylar but a reaction
bracketed by two versions of the same
line the first time Walt screams it
brought family but when he finally
glimpses himself through the eyes of his
family those same words deflate entirely
this is where we can find some insight
in the episode title Ozymandias which
references a sonnet by Percy Shelley
from 1818 in fact it's the poem that
Bryan Cranston reads in a promotional
video for the season showing that Vince
Gilligan and the writers wanted to
highlight this connection the poem tells
the story of Shelley's meeting with a
traveler who describes in detail a
ruined sculpture of Ozymandias the Greek
name for Ramses the second the most
powerful Pharaoh of the Egyptian Empire
and the empty landscape where his great
empire used to stand some of the
parallels here are obvious like this
shot where Walter White falls rigidly to
the ground like a statue crumbling like
Walters frown and wrinkled lip like the
lone and level sands that stretch far
away
Ryan Johnson even stages some visual
flourishes like having the broken glass
of the car window look a lot like Walton
Jesse's blue meth visualizing their
empire fading into the desert like the
poem Breaking Bad is a comment on the
transience of power and the arrogance of
those who acquire it but the poem is
also about seeing through the eyes of
others after all we only see as Amanda's
through the eyes of the sculptor and the
sculptors work through the eyes of the
traveler and the travelers common
through the words of the poet I think
this is so applicable to Breaking Bad
and to this episode particularly because
what makes drama work what makes it
interesting isn't climactic action
scenes or the bombastic declaration of
colorful characters or even big ideas
it's the succession of reactions that
cascade off of every choice the chemical
and emotional reactions of people living
together on earth these days there is an
incredible pressure for showrunners of a
show like this to have an end in mind to
stick the landing with big payoffs and
developments that will shock all of us
while Ozymandias has those things but I
give the writers and director major
credit for sticking to what matters in
an incredibly important episode for
letting us see Walter White King of
Kings undoing the
many eyes of those who loved him there
is a brand new nerdwriter video every
week so if you click that box that I've
set up right there you'll subscribe to
this channel and get all those videos
and I really appreciate that
I have to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring this video they've never
asked to interfere in the content which
is a standard of mine for sponsorships
and they're amazing for that if you
don't know they make sleek intuitive
websites I just made one called the
nerdwriter net you can check that out
and if you sign up for a year you can
get a free domain name and to use the
offer code nerdwriter you can get 10%
off your first purchase thanks guys for
that and I will see you all next
Wednesday